what's up buddy
yo yo
yo ma what's up
oh i've got a great story man it's been
too long since i've got on here and
chopped it up with you so i had to come
on today it's been a minute what's the
word big bird
oh man so
this is a little bit of a story but
hopefully it'll address the topic and
you guys will
learn from my mistakes and not do what i
did so this goes back to my previous ltr
the girl that i
dated right before became red pill we
had the apartment the dog white picket
fence dreams names of kids all picked
out that whole thing right the whole the
next 30 40 years of our lives already
names of kids even oh dude
yeah that's that's pretty serious
yeah i mean it was we knew she we knew
like the date she wanted to get engaged
we had a whole plan for it i mean
everybody should bounce on you again
it was just it was uh
benetization thousand concessions it was
doormat it was coveted let myself go
yeah um and also like i just didn't want
to put up with her bs anymore but i
didn't really have a choice to to leave
i was kind of stuck
uh so early on in the relationship it
was actually a couple of weeks that we
dated before she introduced me to her
friends and she was in a sorority in
college
and so you know how those women are
obsessed with each other and they're
just in the comments section the
instagram oh my god queen like slay me
fire
you're so hot all this bs and so
she introduced me it got to a point
where i was still blue pill and i was
like nervous to meet some like 23 year
old broads and like oh i hope they like
me and so you know i met them and
she had told me basically i found out
that this girl that she'd live with her
roommate her bff
she was obsessed with this girl she had
told me at one point she's like this
girl is the epitome of everything i wish
i could be she looks how i want to look
she gets all the attention i wish i
could have um and so a couple weeks
after we had met i've been coming over
their place a little more and everything
had been fine she calls me and she goes
hey am i going to say her name xyz
uh told me that you know there are some
things that
she
was bothered with by you and i was like
what are we talking about she's like
well and like there was a very
list of three or four extremely
innocuous things
and then she said something along the
lines of like well i'm like okay why are
you telling me this it's like well i'm
not saying i want to break up but i
really care about their opinions and i'm
like okay you're thinking about
the word breakup like literally came out
of your mouth just now because of the
opinion on some of this chick it doesn't
even know me what were the grievances
that she was raising man i think it was
like that i was like i sang in the
shower too loud when i came over there
one time or
they they all had like a shared
apartment it was like a one bedroom with
a huge room that they had put up a wall
that's kind of dorky thing to do
like singing loud in a shower like yeah
but like what i mean i was like whatever
uh enough okay yeah yeah well yeah it is
i agree
but like not loud enough where i thought
they could hear me but what else
i think that like i came into the living
room or like the kitchen to get some
water and she was like the chick was
watching tv but didn't have like any
pants on i was like okay like i didn't
like i'm here you know i'm here like i'm
not walking in on you watching you don't
have pants on there's company here i
don't know what i'm gonna do so just
like very weird things i'm like this is
not a big deal i didn't like make a pass
at her
so you're a bad person for walking
through the room to get water because
she didn't have vegetables essentially
and so
then it goes you can get rid of that guy
girl so we can go ahead again together
right and i was like well was that it
essentially what i i realized was
happening was
my girl at the time before she met me
and even so even now she was very
depressed she was on a bunch of ssris
like her pill bottle was more full than
a sideboard patient
but
i knew that
you know this girl enjoyed
having being a crutch for like my
girlfriend at the time not only that but
she was it was the crabs in the bucket
it was
because my girl was so unhappy
because her life was such a mess
this other chick felt validated and felt
much better about herself because like
well at least that's not my life at
least i'm not you know crying myself to
sleep every night but then when her life
started to get better and she saw me
coming around and she was happier then
she's no longer
like doing so great now she's like why
is she happy i'm not happy well i need
her to be unhappy
this all culminated in another phone
call where my girl called me and she's
like at that point after that phone call
i'm like this girl is my enemy like
we're done like i'm no you're you're
trying to sabotage my relationship like
we're done i'm never talking to you
again well they were having a
housewarming party about a week or two
later and my girl calls me and she's
like hey
uh i need you to basically go out of
your way to go talk to xyz and like make
nice with her and i was like no
i'm like you can't force two people
to have a relationship i know that she's
important to you i'm obviously important
to you and i'll be cordial i'll say
hello to her if i see her if i pass in
the hallway i'll say what's up but
you can't force me to go and try to like
make first of all i didn't do anything
wrong
and two like what am i gonna talk to her
about
and so that this was like probably the
this the beginning of
the long laundry list of tests that
i didn't pass this was the very first
one
and i just said no and she goes okay
well then if you can't do that then
don't even come i don't want you there
and what do you think i did you won
anyway okay
i'll make nice with her i'll do it
whatever you say
and eventually it was fine
um
but that was something where i was like
this was a perfect scenario where this
woman who doesn't even know me is trying
to sabotage my relationship because
she's unhappy with where her life is and
this was a common occurrence so what
would you do in hindsight if that if
that happened again
when i got the phone call about hey she
brought up some problems i'm not saying
i want to break up but there's some
issues and i would have said okay
does her opinion matter you to desert
how much is our opinion matter to the
fact that you would even consider this i
wouldn't even ask her the question
i would say if her opinion of me matters
so much
that you would even consider ending a
relationship with me like
we can go ahead and just be done that's
okay nice knowing you enjoy your
relationship with what's-her-name
uh because
we're we're done and i would have ended
it right there and if i didn't if i
wouldn't have done that i wouldn't have
gone to the party would have soft next
it i mean i probably would have should
have broken up right there when she
called me saying
my friends don't like you and i don't
know what to do it's like i'll make it
really easy for you we're done
and that would have been it
but without that
red pill wouldn't have read the stuff
wouldn't be here today so can't be all
bad
yeah there's always a silver lining in
every you know that happens to
guys it's it's just you know you have to
embrace it so hey man i'm glad you got
through that's a great story um if you
guys want to catch up with moth and
jiren they'll be on stereo after the
show
uh just download the app stereo and look
for moth as you see it yeah
stereo dot com slash mobile forgot to
put the dot com come chop it up with us
afterwards guys thank you man appreciate
it all right
you